turning globally we passed another major
global milestone in this pandemic there
are now more than 5 million reported
cases of the corona virus that's
worldwide yesterday the World Health
Organization announced the highest
single day increase since the crisis
began with a hundred and six thousand
new cases but there is hope from some
new studies suggesting people who've
recovered from the virus do become
immune dr. Ashish Jha is the director of
the Harvard Global Health Institute he
joins us now from Boston dr. Joe glad to
have you on with us this morning
rarely do we get to report these days on
good news regarding the corona virus but
we have these new studies the first one
involves monkeys who appeared not to be
reinfected after they've already had the
virus what does that tell us about
people yeah so good morning and you know
we usually don't get super excited about
animal studies because we want to see
this in humans but these are rhesus Mac
monkeys were very close biologically to
humans and I think it's just good news
that it looks like once you recover from
the virus you really do have immunity at
least in monkeys we got to test it
obviously in humans but I think I see
this as good news there's another bit of
research from Emory University not
peer-reviewed yet but promising seems to
suggest that people hospitalized with
COBIT 19 develop antibodies within six
days under a week what does that tell us
about a vaccine timeline and and and how
good is the news overall yeah so again
you know this is a small study other
studies have found it takes a little
longer but almost every study is finding
that after you've been infected and you
clear the infection you do develop
antibodies and again all the evidence
right now points to the idea that those
antibodies are going to be protective
and it's going to protect you from
developing the infection again so
possibly there could be something like
an immunity passport for people who have
already had the virus but let's talk
about a vaccine because a lot of people
are waiting on one the Trump
administration hopes to have a vaccine
by the end of the year people have
called that a credible goal but is it
realistic if you're making personal or
financial decisions based on a vaccine
would you bet on it yeah I think the
idea of having a vaccine in 2020 would
is obviously be wonderful but it is
highly highly unlikely just all the
things that we still need to do between
testing it and animals and actually
being able to give it to humans and know
that it's safe and effective I think
this can be very hard to pull off in
2020 I am pretty optimistic that we're
gonna have a vaccine in some time in
2021 my best guess is probably in the
middle of 2021 but I'd love to be wrong
I'd love for it to be earlier all right
I like the optimism that we will get
something eventually just maybe not this
year I want to talk about two practical
matters the first one cloth face masks
many businesses requiring them of
customers going back many governors
saying that they work but yesterday dr.
osterholm a prominent researcher from
the University of Minnesota caused a bit
of a stir by saying the research on
cloth masks is not good and it may give
people a false sense of security so I
want to put the question to you is it
helpful for people to wear cloth face
masks as they go out and do their
business so I think I think it is
helpful I think what dr. Osler phone was
saying which I agree with is it's not a
substitute for everything else it's not
a substitute for social distancing
keeping six feet away washing your hands
if you think the cloth mask is good
enough and you don't do anything else
that probably is risky but cloth mask on
top of all the other things we've been
doing I think is added protection so
let's talk about some of those other
things we've been doing this CDC is now
saying that the virus does not seem to
survive well on surfaces does that mean
we can stop wearing gloves as some
people do in public does that mean we
don't have to wash down groceries we can
go a little bit easier on those fronts
yeah so I believe that you know the data
that's coming out is that is it that
most of the transmission is really
people to people or not from surfaces
and therefore I don't think there's much
reason to be wearing gloves out in
public it is critical not to touch your
face and touch your eyes with your hands
wash your hands
I'd never really believe that washing
groceries are wiping them down with
Clorox wipes is necessary and I think
more and more the evidence is you don't
need to do that just I can wash your
hands carefully and you know and then
from other people stay away at least six
feet and do all the stuff that we've
been doing all right dr. Ashish Shaw
walking us through some positive news
this morning on the corona virus doctor
thank you very much